is uh could you uh get uh share your
screen with us
uh make sure everything's working um
yeah devops if you if you um look back
at his history he's
uh was a star a grad student at mit
and then all his awards
one after one were labeled as a rising
star or something similar
so i don't think it can be called an
official star at mit and
statistical inference machine learning
operations research
and um fantastic teacher as well so
look forward to your talk all right well
sean thanks for a kind introduction
uh i guess i uh since my
first grad first in grad school i
remember your talk at the stochastic
networks
and since then it's been pleasure
following you
so with that i'm going to talk about
a method for q learning
in a data efficient manner using a
matrix estimation
approach and here the key result is that
if you view the traditional queue
function
in the mdps as a kernel of an operator
then turns out there is a nice way to
define the spectral representation of it
and which could lead to utilizing the
traditional matrix estimation approach
as a subroutine to obtain
efficient q-learning method
and as i walk through the talk i will
talk about
the spectral representation and how
that fits nicely with the matrix
estimation
and my hope is that this talk would
present um
an avenue to further exploration rather
than
a complete results i feel that there are
many of the results here
are the first take on the question and
hopefully
a little bit when you to get both
feedback as well as
find uh many of the uh
many of the bright ones as an audience
uh thinking about the next set of
questions
uh this is based on a thesis of uh dog
young song and z
zoo who are a graduate students at mit
along in collaboration with usa yang
uh all right so with that let me get
started and again goes without saying
that
please feel free to ask me questions
feel free to unmute yourself at any
point of time
uh and interrupt me
okay so this is based on the manuscript
titled sample efficient rl with low rank
matrix estimation
uh it's going to appear in eurips this
year and also
it's available on the archive
okay so just to set things up as we've
seen
many times um in this
meeting uh we're going to talk about uh
the standard mdp framework
we're going to consider infinite horizon
discounted
setting that is we got the state space s
exchange space a the transition kernel
i got a reward function and then the
discount factor
okay as we know
if there's a policy pi that maps state
to action we define the value function
as this
and of course uh the optimal value
function is the one that is achieved
through an optimal policy and again
there exists a nice clean optimal policy
that leads to
the definition of this as a value
function
another quantity of interest has been
discussed many time in the meeting is
the
q function in particular the optimal q
function an optimal q function defines
the bellman's equation
that is it simply now instead of value
function
equations of state and action and then
define in this natural
recursive manner and of course
the value function at a given state is
nothing but the maximum over
or supremum over a for q
defined at the and of course this q
function the nice thing about it is it
gives you explicitly what policy
is and that's defined as this
equation so really one way to think
about
rl is simply look for
estimating q or q star that is we would
like to
learn an approximation of q star
which is minimizing with respect to the
infinity nor
and that will be our goal
now since
bellman's equation has a fixed point
as q star in such setting naturally
gives rise to the traditional queue
learning policy and here is
one version of q learning that i'm
writing down where
if i am observing data
uh in terms of sequence of states
actions rewards and then the next states
then i could iteratively update my q
function estimate
by simply looking at equations such as
this and again you want to
choose the right step size so that the
convergence happens but at the same time
accumulation happens
as well okay so far so good
this is a quick recap of the context
the key question of interest in this
work
is coming up with estimation
of uh q star uh in particular we want to
find q hat so that its
infinite normal error is less than
epsilon in a data efficient manner so
what is data here
data here is the number of simulation
steps so in this setup
i'm going to assume access to a
simulation environment that is given
state and action
i could simulate from the underlying
model what the next state would be and
what the reward associated would be
okay so question is that how many
simulation steps do i need
to obtain such an estimator
um i'm going to focus on
um uh continuous state space
that is number of states are in finite
in that sense
but we'll consider a nice compact sets
uh in particular
for simplicity think of the state being
a unit interval in given dimension and
state
action would be the 0 comma 1 to power
d2
in another dimension and again if you if
it's easy just think of d1 equals to d2
equals to some fixed d
and again our interest would be
understanding
the sample complexity with respect to
the scaling of epsilon and d i see there
is a
q a uh question uh not sure
if i should uh pause it and figure out
how to
look at it okay so get grow ask is there
any particular reason for using
infinity norm uh well
one is well it's a best type or tightest
form of
approximation error one could get and
also having
um q infinity norm because we're going
to use the q
hat to define a policy it also gives me
how much error would i have if i made a
decision based on the q
q hat so that's uh the reason why i'm
thinking about q infinity now i hope
girgo it answers your question
okay so i'm going to continue
i'm going to assume that of mdps how
optimal queue function which is lip
sheets
defined this way and again there's
simple generic conditions that will lead
to on the
problem set up that will lead to such
property on uh
q function okay
now under such setting um
there's a nice minimax lower bounds
exist
for this problem uh which says that
the number of samples required must
scale as epsilon to power minus d1 plus
d2
plus 2 as it scales both with the
dimensions of state space and action
space in this map
in this manner more precisely uh
if it's finite state then it's a simply
product of state
and action space and one way to think
about
why these two results are identical is
because
if you are thinking about learning
uh q star within epsilon error
one way to do that is roughly speaking
is take the states
and action space and uh simply
discretize or quantize them within
epsilon
and that will lead to um the number of
let's say cells
in that quantization uh scaling is
epsilon to power minus d1 for s
and epsilon to power minus d2 for a for
these reasons and there's a
plus two here that happens and this type
of lower bound one ways to think about
them is to simply reduce the traditional
uh uh nonparametric
regression questions or function
learning
now again these are minimax and hence
these are adversarial
pessimistic but in practice we would
hope that there are many situations
where
mdps do have some structure and if they
do have some structure hopefully
maybe we could utilize that structure in
a meaningful manner
and improve upon such powers so
to paraphrase this one way to ask
question is that are there
representations
for mdps that allow us to define some
notion of parametric complexity and as
that parameter changes complexity of mdp
changes
which translates effectively into more
or less data requirement
and with this as a motivation
what in this work we do is we try to
pursue one such representation
and one such representation uh is what
we'll call
the traditional spectral representation
so what we're thinking about is
again uh generic abstract setting would
be that you got
um state and exp action space which are
endowed with appropriate metric are
compact metric spaces with finite
measures
uh there is a bounded reward function
and as i mentioned earlier the q
function is lipschitz with respect to
these
metric now if we think of
q star which is a function of state and
action
think of this as a kernel inducing an
operator
an operator on the l2 space from action
space to
the state space then under these
conditions
one can write down a nice simple uh
clean
um singular value decomposition of such
such q star which has a countable
representation that is the number of
components in its representation
are countably infinite further the
singular values associated with them
are square sumable which means that in
that sense
energy is always finite
now we hope that this result is known in
some form
somewhere uh not necessarily in the
context of q
star but at least in the generalized
singular value decomposition sense
try to look for literature of course for
the well known for symmetric for
asymmetric setting which is what q star
is
just had to work work it out from basic
principles okay but again i'm pretty
sure there is a appropriate reference
somewhere
one implication of this is that
if you for any given q star for any
delta greater than zero there will exist
a finite rank r of delta
such that if i truncated this
expansion to top ours components
then in this l2 sense it will be
within error delta okay
so which means that not only uh
this has um a finite energy
because of that finite energy it has a
finite rank approximation with
approximation error delta
for any given delta of course the
question is that
how fast does r of delta dk is a
function of delta that's an interesting
study and
for uh anyways i'll leave that as an
interesting question to think about
there are a few things we know
um for a nice analytic functions and so
on and so forth but i'm going to sort of
spare us from that for the time being
okay uh now with this in the tradition
the way we think of uh
rank i would define rank of q star
as the smallest i beyond which the
singular values are zero
or delta rank in this sense
okay if there's any questions please
feel free to stop me or
post it on q and i'll try to see if i
can monitor
okay so with that um
just to remind us that sort of this what
happens to some of the classical
questions like
classical lqr or linear quadratic
regular setting where you know
we have a linear system
and in this case let's say state and
action space are individual dimension as
defined before
okay we have a quadratic
cost or negative reward
and of course in this case as we know
policies of interest and linear policies
that would lead to the q function that
has
a nice uh explicit form
and a moment or two of deliberation
would convince you that in this case
the this q function for any pi has a
finite rank in particular
the rank is uh minimum of
the d1 plus d1 comma d2 plus 2.
and so indeed there are examples where
uh the optimal uh q
function has finite rank and as we
discussed
for uh any lipschitz q function
uh the delta rank is finite
okay so with this here is the overview
of main result
so if we assume that the optimal
q function is finite rank and discount
factor gamma is small enough smaller
than
uh predefined constant or universal
constant
then um
[Music]
the sample complexity of learning q star
within epsilon with respect to infinity
norm
scales as 1 over maximum of d1
comma d2 so for simplicity let's think
of d1 equals to d2 then it says
this is scales like epsilon to power
minus d
plus minus d minus 2
compared to a lower bound which is 2d
so in a sense we go from 2 times d to
single d
and again that's happening is because we
have a finite rank and there is a
within here there is a constant hidden
that depends on
rank r so of course if r goes to
infinity
this result would become vectors in some
sense you would
lead to this one or rather a bound such
as this
uh in the context of finite state in
action what this would mean is that
instead of having a multiplicative
bound it would have the max of s comma a
the same manner
so again uh this is because the
q function is finite rank and discount
factor is small enough
okay and bunch of references associated
with these are here
go to uh move on so how does
how does this work so in next 10 minutes
or so i'll try to
quickly go through the key ideas of how
the
low rank representation of q star
in in this
spectral sense leads to efficient q
learning algorithm
so the first insight was that well if we
have some finite set of states uh and
finite set of actions and if we simply
look at the q
function evaluated those finite states
and actions
so not infinite but finite then
if you look at a matrix with rows being
the
finitely some many sample states and
columns being finitely many sample
actions and q star of s comma a being
the entry of that matrix
and because the q star is finite rank in
the way we defined
the sampled version or sampled matrix is
has a finite
rank in particular rank no more than r
in the traditional um matrix sense
so if you have finite rank and if you
know
exact value for roughly r
times the maximum of the dimension of
the matrix
then the traditional matrix estimation
literature would suggest that we should
be able to recover
all the entries
pretty accurately so that means that
if only by having
to estimate let's say n by n
entries and square entries we needed
access to only
order n entries so the question is that
how can we
why not apply that as an approach the
few challenges are that
well we don't have direct access to
qstart because that's what we're trying
to estimate
and that recursively depends on each
other and second is the state and
actions
spaces are not finite and so we need to
somehow figure out
iteratively refine and achieve this and
that's precisely what we do
so in pictures roughly the algorithm
looks something like this so
we're trying to do uh effectively
queue learning but in a specific manner
okay
so let's suppose we so again these are
the inputs you start with some
initialization
and so initially you have a continuous
state space
on which you have some initially trade q
naught
first we do is that we discretize this
state space and so we've got finite set
of states and finite set of actions
and this is the matrix of interest for
this matrix of interest what we're going
to do
and that's the quantization okay
the next step what we're going to do is
we're going to do exploration in
particular
for a subset of entries in this matrix
in a specific manner
we would choose the state and action
which corresponds to one of the
action entries here we'll draw
and t appropriately defined
simulations from the simulator that we
have access to
and using that we're getting nt samples
for the next state
and using that along with the reward
here i'm assuming it's deterministic but
let's say if not
average we produce a new estimate
with the estimate that we had from the
previous iteration
okay and again since there's a discount
factor
if we had some error before discount
that discount factor shrinks that error
by some amount of course there is some
error because of
um averaging but let's say it's not the
case
then sort of definitely this discounting
helps reduce some error
that was there from previous step so
that means that we started with some
estimation here
of q function on these sample
states our error has reduced by some
amount however we have only access to
these few sample states and actions not
everything
we'll utilize the matrix estimation to
complete this entries in matrix in the
process we might
lose on some of the gains that we made
through this step but hopefully if you
have a good
estimation good matrix estimation
procedure
this loss may not be too much and once
we have these sample things and because
these
sampling or this quantization was done
carefully with
appropriate method uh gener
interpolation method for example like
just here we just used
nearest neighbors it would
generalize reasonably well and again so
there'll be some loss
in this generalization also so we gained
we lost and we lost but hopefully the
losses made are less than the gains
uh made here then effectively in this
end of this
one loop we went from
qt minus 1 to qt by improving
in terms of our accuracy or reducing the
error
now i see that there's one more there's
a question in q and a so let me stop
there for a second
and see what the question is so you
don't ask questions
hi you don't good to see you online uh
when the action speech is small say one
and two does this approach achieve
better sample
complexity than tabular approach well uh
the short answer you don't is no because
then
a matrix estimation that the gain you
are obtaining
are definitely uh disappearing as you
know because
you want both dimension to scale well so
thank you for asking the question
okay uh i'm going to continue um
with the description
okay so another way to look at the same
algorithm is that you start with some
iteration
first you go from that iteration and
reduce the error okay
uh by through exploration
and then you may begin lose a little bit
when you go from this estimation through
matrix estimation and you lose a little
bit more when you go to generalization
but hope is that as you're going from
here to here to here
you are gaining and working towards your
ultimate q star
okay so in summary here's the type of
result you can obtain through a method
like this that if you have
a matrix estimation method which
for so matrix of interest is
m um
you have sampled this matrix for a small
subset of entries
these entries may have some error
let's say this is the infinity norm
error restricted to the observed entries
with respect to
m and m hat so that means the error is
arbitrary
from this m hat you obtain m bar
using the matrix estimation such that m
bar minus
the original m in infinity norm is some
constant factor times
the error in your observations okay
and let's assume that you can achieve
this by observing such entries for
a subset of entries which scales uh edit
linearly in the two dimensions with some
another constant
if you have access to such an oracle of
matrix estimation
which we'll call as satisfying capital c
small c
matrix estimation property then we can
for choices of quantization
number of samples and the iteration at
each step to
construct that exploration can come up
with a
method that allows us to produce
estimation of
q star at the t iteration with respect
to infinity norm
that decays exponentially
with this constant now um when i'm
saying it decays
i'm assuming that this is true
so this is where it was when i sort of
stated overview of the result i said
gamma should be less than some universal
constant that is this universal
constant which comes from the matrix
estimation
and clearly
this cme has to be greater than or equal
to 1
because that's the worst case
adversarial error we might have
so that means that gamma has to be less
than or equal to half now of course
this is uh if we tighten the analysis
then we can make
gamma as close to 1 over cme
as possible question is that can we have
a method that
achieves cme close to one well if we
observe
all the entries yes that is feasible but
the whole point is that
we don't want to observe all entries we
want to observe only linear number of
entries in the dimension not the
quadratic
and question is what is the best
trade-off you can achieve
more precisely a question that would you
would ask is that
is it feasible to achieve uh
is it is it feasible for such an article
to exist because in existing matrix
estimation literature such a matrix
estimation did not exist
anyways what we
do argue in the in our paper is that yes
there is such
a matrix estimation method that does
exist
uh using that with appropriate choice we
can achieve
uh the results that we claimed earlier
okay
so one interesting question that remains
open is that well we have achieved
such shown the existence of such a thing
for potentially not optimized constants
questions what are the optimal constants
you can achieve for such a matrix
estimation
uh requirement that remains uh
an interesting question and sort of a
kind of a nice tie up between
the reinforcement learning method and
the matrix estimation literature
in one minute i'll quickly show how it
works
in some of the simple experiments so
again this is
uh one of the simplest examples as we
know
of inverted pendulum sort of defining
and reminding us i'll just quickly walk
you through the type of results
empirical results we get
so what i'm showing here is the infinity
norm error
and here is the number of samples in 10
to the power 7
times number of that and as you can see
with matrix estimation based approach
this error decays
quickly versus this is the standard
baseline
q learning approach okay and again so
this happens
for gamma equals to 0.5 gamma equals to
0.9
and this is just for l1 error so the
takeaway is that while
our results were true for small gamma
in practice they work for gamma getting
close to one
which seem to suggest that maybe our
analysis is uh
weaker rather than the method itself
this is showing the same thing but
instead of using the method that we
proposed
other uh matrix estimation method while
these methods don't have
guarantees that is probably known
guarantees
were almost as good as the best uh
r approach so uh in particular i would
like to call out nuclear
minimization which seem to be by little
bit but
constantly outperforming our approach
which uh definitely something to uh
worth proving that uh type of guarantee
this is just a visual plot of the method
showing that it works uh
it works what it promises all right so
with that
i'm close to the end of my time um
again uh the key takeaway is that
spectral representation provides a nice
parametric way of thinking about
complexity
uh there's a nice connection to low rank
matrix estimation with
different types of guarantees and
hopefully
uh folks might be might sort of find
better ways to prove tighter guarantees
there and going forward just
characterizing mdps that have such lower
anchor approximate loading structure
would be a great set of uh questions to
look at so let me pause here
uh fantastic um i'm sure there must be
lots of questions
none q and a but out there
so um could you go back to you you
rushed past that
that visualization um the visualization
of the policies was that or the um
yeah i was just wondering if it if you
smooth things or introduce
um um noise when you do this i just
wonder
empirically what you found in terms of
the kind of distortion that you see
you've been hearing thoughts but you had
a visualization of a policy
i guess maybe last plot oh i see here
you mean
like there yeah yeah yeah the red flag
there with all the
uh you see a method yes this is yeah
just a few ruffles
i'd love to see what happens with
something like mountain car where the
belly function is very non-smooth and if
this
smooths it if it makes it blow up or
something like that
yeah so we tried with few examples and
again it's it's very similar
uh behavior but again sort of we have
not tried with very complicated examples
right and is there any way to like to
either take
cost information to account or you know
or
or the or a smoothness somehow try to
have a smoothie or something like that
you know
yeah so for example one way to argue
that let's say
um something like this kind of guarantee
um that q function is lipschitz is to
have
appropriate property of of the report
function
and the the transition kernel so you've
got that in there
but you're not using that in your model
or your algorithm are you
sorry those those are used to obtain
uh bounds right exactly so if for
example one way to guarantee
this kind of smoothness of q star would
be to
wire the smoothness of reward function
and the transition kernel oh sure
what i meant was does your algorithm
respect the which is constant or do you
get something roughly
ah good um
okay so i don't remember so but we
i think the dependence on constants like
lipschitz constant
and the rank are not
uh let's call it the very respectable
yeah
so they're constants but uh i do believe
that there might be a room to improve
them
uh as well um there's a nice comment
here
in the q a um the category
of trust decomposition or similar
methods might help
sorry so okay do you think categorical
uh category of cholesky well so i think
um um it's a great question there's all
sorts of matrix estimation method would
help so
this is a particularly hard setup
because we are thinking of the following
thing that
i have a matrix m i'm going to give you
observation where
each observation has an error and the
error is
bounded but it's adversarial so there is
no
it may it may be it may have a serious
biases and the question is that with
such an adversarial setting how would
you recover the
original matrix for all the entries
while retaining the same amount of
adversarial error
may be blown up by a constant factor but
not by much
and that is a hard problem
we could sort of find that by uh
selecting the appropriate sort of uh
query points in the matrix
um and it would be really interesting to
sort of analyze other methods
with respect to this a very uh
very strong requirement for example we i
bel we believe that sort of nuclear norm
minimization
must have some such property but it's at
least we found it hard to prove but
one of the commentaries so gamma was
your discount factor right
that's correct so so the uh question of
how to
uh remove dependency on the discount
factor
was the topic aditya devaraj's talk
yesterday
so
uh deborah and i've ever never bought
sorry
and um and uh
if there i mean of course uh contact all
the uh
speakers and um if you have questions
and uh come back tomorrow we'll have
another very interdisciplinary
um day on people from control and nrl
it's gonna be a panel as well which is
gonna be good
and if you have any questions by the way
for the panelists tomorrow send them to
us in advance you know just uh
all the entropy the more interview the
better um
the panel yesterday was basically let's
find out what chava knows that was sort
of
and the theme gonna we're not gonna have
that theme tomorrow we're gonna have a
different theme
um so same question
that's great yeah thanks a lot thank you
great to see you it's just a shame you
know without berkeley
exactly yeah i wish it was berkeley yeah
at least it will be nice and warm yeah
right even here
on the freeze winding you know before
right okay good job